they don't want those people that's
crazy if you live in New York City you
must leave immediately why look at New
York City when colan was explaining how
New York City literally has a mandate to
house its homeless yeah and that was
supposed to be the people that lived
there that were down on their luck and
now it's people that have come in from
other cities and or other countries
rather illegally and they're trying to
make it so that those people can vote
and you see what they're doing with
people from Venezuela crazy they're
sending people back from Venezuela only
from Venezuela yeah because Venezuela
opposes socialism so they're not going
to vote Democratic they don't want those
people that's crazy it's crazy how it's
so like when you start thinking about it
like that that sounds like a conspiracy
theory but it's like totally political
all these moves 100% yeah they're
they're literally importing Democratic
voters they think by allowing the
borders to be poorest and by giving
people Aid and giving people housing
that you're essentially guaranteeing
that if you can rig it so that those
people are allowed to vote those people
are going to vote Democratic and if you
could say that oh voter ID is racist
like what voter ID is crazy that that's
they think that and they don't think
that they don't think that they know
that that's not true it's it's all
political
hor